se faccio lo faccio sarà
benvenuti bastare oggi due vittime video
super speciale avete capito dove ci
troviamo
siamo al parco giochi da da parte di
ritornate tempo fa abbiamo già fatto un
video quali è piaciuto stanza vivo ci
hanno ospitato nuovamente qua alta da
farti e oggi fare un video speciale e ci
giocheremo a rho blocks nella vita reale
se questo video raggiunge i 20 mila casi
la più viva da par quindi lasciati un
bel mi piace prodotte vi ricordate
questa ludoteca data parti enormi soldi
ci sono due soli quindi sarà super
divertente questo robot nella vita reale
ringraziamo da da parti per averci
ospitato e
subito
primo quadro della nostra challenge di
rom se dobbiamo superare questi ostacoli
questo il primo quadro del partito per
ora è molto semplice bisogna evitare gli
ostacoli ma è che è molto e cubitale che
ricomincia deve evitare gli ostacoli non
devi andarci contro
guarda
avanti
fatta
questa super difficile ci aiuta piano
piano
veniamo cliccata
[Musica]
ecco mi tocca a me superare questo
quadro devo sbrigarmi perché è vitale
già più avanti e ovviamente vincere chi
finisce prima il parkour e prende il bel
finale per primo quindi rinviamo c'è un
piccolo ostacolo
io in realtà un trucchetto perché ho le
carte con questi gommini sotto quindi
scivolo meno forse deve facilissimo qua
mi basta camminare
ed evitare tutti gli ostacoli si apre il
primo ostacolo e poi
aspetta un momento duro devastato qua
vero ho preso la scorciatoia solo
passato di qua
ce l'ho fatta devo completare questo
quadro che inizia di qua e finisce alla
giu
adesso devo sbrigarmi amita sta
arrivando corro
sembra un cono di gelato
quindi non è un cono di gelato e come
evitare di store aggiunge
ma che sta facendo vitale ma forse il
cono è solo questo giallo andiamo a
prenderlo
sempre il solito che si deve sfracellare
10.000 volte è meglio così
approfittiamone superiamo lo
permetto permesso permetto
come faccio a salire la sopra
sicuramente devo evitare quello perché
vitale non è tornato in vita ancora
toccare questo non sono aggiornati ma
vatti vede benissimo che non sono gelati
quante volte disprezzo e l'auto già 3 4
2 secondo voi chi vincerà questa
challenge io ho vitale ma soprattutto
quante volte si sbriciolerà di tale
credo non è come t e ora meglio che tu
pro vita
però passano via tavo pe così di salire
sopra come si fa salire la stop rai
quando
ma è che stai facendo
sbagliato strada non è questa
e vero non è questa penso perché poi c'è
uno scivolo quindi bisogna salire su se
dice una scorciatoia è un po un
labirinto questo ei ma qua è tutto
chiuso dove dobbiamo andare io devo
sbrigarmi vado
non mi scappi
non toccare le pareti altri migliori
il lettore attento non toccare qua ok ok
devo cercare di spostarmi qua senza
toccare niente
è fatta
vediamo se vitale ce la farà sì se ho
capito
che così
tanto tu non ci passi da lì come lo ci
passo stavo facendo il delfino
spiaggiato vivaio prodotto scorciatoia
io avevo detto di non toccare come
sempre vitale non mi ascom
è meglio che non tocco questi ostacoli
comunque come sempre evitare non mi
ascolta chi c'è una scorciatoia ma è
impossibile passare perché troppo
stretto e non bisogna toccare di altre
parti quindi
ma non lo si può affidare lui continuerà
a proporre sa dire uno sopra che cosa
devi dire a vitale niente niente fai
pure
sopra
nel mentre che vitale continua a
sfracellarsi o passo cosa avanti
cercando di superare questi ostacoli
sperando che sia la strada giusta e non
che la strada giusta sia quella di sopra
ma lo scopriremo molto preziosa questa è
la strada giusta
certo che no quella in cui
stacco cento sta strisciando verso qua
espressiva non toccare la parte di sopra
ha deciso di seguirmi
vai piano è
pacata la difficoltà
faccio lo faccio sarda
povero vitale mi fa un buffet era quante
volte distanza fra celant beh almeno
sono inventate noi facciamo
meno male hai tante vite come i gatti
anche se dovrei essere io un gatto in
questo caso comunque super divertente
questa sala insieme a rob lowe nella
vita reale
per dire sì sì mi sono state quelle
volte già proprio come nel videogioco
infatti vado avanti io no io ho quello
che mi ha superato
e vi ha superato devo inventarmi subito
qualcosa è vitale ho trovato una cosa
bellissima
ai presenti coni gelato che cercavi
prima come se un cono gelato gigante qua
uno al cioccolato e uno alla vaniglia
d'oro ci caschi bye bye cambia dai veri
no non ci credo che è riuscito a passare
in mezzo come ho fatto io in mezzo di
traverso non onora e ci provo io sto
arrivando
[Musica]
hai toccato
ok di lato
cieli volta a dare adesso non lo so io
sto provando da questa parte un po a
caso ma come a casa io stavo seguendo
tempo è stato che fa bene né mai
inseguire sai come sono le cose non le
so quali sono vabbè che sta facendo
vitale crede davvero di riuscire a
passare la in mezzo si ritira
[Musica]
ho fatto
sei morti perché entro casa news e bra
che stai facendo fermo
ma che stai facendo
vitali non riesce più ad alzarsi in
piedi aspetto ma dove siamo
era questa la porta giusta ma ti sei
accorta adesso che è tornato dove il
primo bene questa è l'occasione giusta
perché mentre vitale incastrato là
dentro
io posso tornare di là alle entrate e
provare a salire da sopra nella parte
che abbiamo visto prima ciao ciao vitale
bordo ero io non ce l'ho io ci provo da
qui che stai facendo
no che sto facendo di di vedere una
botta
è un po di volo avevano scivolo web ecco
perché guarda che non riesce a salire
dalla stoffa che infatti si scivola ti
conviene tornare indietro
dai secondo me puoi farcela provaci
ancora
evitare che una singola ma alle casse
troppo si muove
dai riprovo puoi farcela
riprovaci varie volte così rimarrai lì
per un bel po di tempo io nel frattempo
basta dire qualcosa c'è un altro
passaggio
italy sta continuando a provare a salire
dallo scivolo ma non penso che ci
riuscirà mai rivedete
penso di riuscirci a salire costo pro ma
ci provo ma che sta facendo vitale
pronto a sparire da li
guarda che non si può apparire da riva
che poi è scomparso
ok devo cercare di non toccare niente
sono riuscita ora la parte più difficile
solo le gambe
posso toccare la parte gialla ma non
posso toccare la parte verde di sotto
problema è che non posso toccare neanche
questa parte vetta
ho avuto un'idea migliore vi ricordate
che vi ho detto che io le calze con i
gommini sotto antiscivolo potrei
riuscire a salire dallo scivolo perché
passare qualche è difficilissimo andiamo
ok eccomi tornata qua devo solo superare
questi ostacoli adesso ma dov'è finito
vitale non c'è più
che è uscito dal gioco
forse si era stancato perché si è
sfracellato così tante volte che ha
deciso di uscire dal gioco che strano va
beh noi continuiamo
ma come ha fatto prima vitale a passare
qua forse devo per forza buttarmi ok
ecco mi devo buttarvi
quasi quasi faccio un riposino qua no
che potrebbero evitare e anche finirò di
stupro e prendere il belgio prima di
vitale proviamo a salire dallo scivolo
con le mie calzanti cibo ok ma le calze
antiscivolo coni combini e anche le
orecchie da gatto proprio come un vero
gas
andiamo ecco qua lo scivolo
o no la mia calza si vola lo stesso
maestà ball e calze antiscivolo
dovrebbero non farmi scivolare ma
scivolano lo stesso in questo caso
sarebbe stato utile vitale per aiutarmi
mi avrebbe potuto dare una mano e
trascinarmi sopra riproviamo
devo provare a salire velocissimo 21
posso farcela
inutile non ce la faccio sarà più di
dubitare perché ha lasciato il gioco
proprio adesso bisogno del suo aiuto
non ce la farò mai
ma tu sei qua lità le aspetta ti do una
mano sì dai ti do una mano
è certo dai tv roso io ok grazie
ma ce la fai ce la facciamo più alti e
mi aspetta un momento ma tu prima mi hai
fatto strage la re migliaia di volte
[Musica]
beh ne pentirai mi vendicherò maritati o
fregata io continuo le skype room ciao
mia imbrogliata
inserisce evitare tutti gli ostacoli
un altro ostacolo
ma come stai camminando
dentro al tubo
abitare sta continuando andare avanti io
non riesco a salire in questo sembra
quasi piccolo questo schifo lo sembra
così facile sa dirci ma è difficilissimo
beh mi resta solo una cosa tornare
indietro e riprovare a salire dalla
ok posso toccare il giallo ma non il
verde
devo spostare qua
ok
qua devo toccare
ma come facesse di questa operazione
verde
devo per forza a baciarmi qua
per fortuna in questa possa appoggiarmi
ce l'ho fatta ma è dovere di dare prima
lo riconoscete vedete quello e riuscì
volo e vitale proprio impastato
eccolo stai ricordo che cosa vuole fare
arrivando acqua
ennesimo sfracella mente di vitale di
sbrigarmi magari pazzo tila perché non
vi è imbrigliata prima nello scivolo
quindi lasciato prima
che abbia avuto a vitale altrimenti mi
butterà negli ostacoli
arrivando
verbali
ei ma che fai ti diro
20 questi ostacoli ma dove sta scappando
da un momento
non c'è una via d'uscita qua è
effettivamente era un po che giravo in
torno qui si passa di qua tornado vero
prima qual è la via d'uscita allora non
lo so ma
credo sia quella l'uscita c'è anche il
badge vero dobbiamo trovare il modo di
andare laggiù è sì allora dobbiamo
tornare al piano di sotto
credo proprio di sì e io credo di essere
avvantaggiato perché da qui è più facile
che stai facendo mi stai tracciato la
strada che sei tu capita intralciando no
mi metto qui dovrei passare da dire
membri in brook dentro una mela verde
vorrà dire che mi trasformerò era una
bellissima farfalla addio fermo passo da
questa parte allora in questo tubo
giallo
è giallo
azzurro
20 st così impari a correre io meglio
che vado piano così lievito di
sfracellarsi un sacco di gol questo è un
aiutante sembra proprio un personaggio 0
blocks
credevi fosse il resto è invece no vado
avanti
ma serviranno limitazioni scivolo devo
andare a prendere aggiunge ad abitare
non devo toccare le reti e non devo
cadere
per fortuna questa casta
ce l'ha fatta è andato
nello chiffon ciao ciao perdente
sto arrivando ai fermo lì allora di
raggiunto subito
[Musica]
dov'è andato
io sono il vantaggio
però penso abbia 2000
ahia ahia
spiaccicato in questo ostacolo sì ma
aspetta cielo c'era
riuscito era qua
indagine ti amo accorti noi siamo soli
diritti della sopra ma non si terrà qui
a fianco come mai non tenere accordo
vabbè vitale fa cercando di evitare
l'ostacolo
riuscita a
vita levi sta superando devo correre sta
arrivando al peggio
[Musica]
be nice
dopo avere preso
vitale è caduto due volte
ora che lui e la terra possa
approfittarne prendere il badge prima di
lui enti fanno persino cadario kg
si
no
ho
visto ho capito
siccome ho vinto ti aiuta
scivolano through anche di barbe già chi
sei libero esprima to
the broom
superata ma che sto facendo
ei papà se volete mandare un altro e tv
ma anche nell'altra area da farci
mazzate un bel mi piace a 20 mila mi
piace fare molti chiamarmi a 20 mila mi
piace parlare la morte di rob lowe nella
vita reale riflettiamo ancora da una
parte per averci ospitato potete trovare
da da parti in via di circonvallazione
di lizzanello 56 a lecce cavallino
stelline cliccare per vedere i nostri
altri video cliccate su quella che
preferite buona visione